hello everybody my name is markiplier
don't laugh when I'm doing my intro man
my name is Mark Martin welcome back to
crash bandicoot the original game I'm
going back on the high road picking up
exactly where I left off now I'm
thinking if I don't be an idiot about
things and I calmed down and I just take
my flipped [ __ ] time I'll be just
fine so yeah yes just I just gotta use
my brain I've just got to think about
what I'm off what I'm doing in the dude
don't you're gonna make me faster though
I don't like that you make me faster oh
I don't like how that handles now okay
you're dead how long does this last and
why and also what okay oh god damn it
can I make that jump though yeah no I
can't
god dammit it's fine everything's cool
Donald get through this that's how I do
that's what I do that's how I do things
in this neighborhood yeah yeah okay
right on threading the needle really
that's what you're gonna do to me on my
return back into this when I'm calm and
collected which I am nobody say
otherwise get the trick to these turtles
the trick to these turtles is just
patience no
there we go that's barely making it
though that's it's such a tight margin
of error ah like this one is just okay
I'm gonna do what I was doing before
we're just watching my shadows even
though I see myself sliding off blank oh
my god I'm not gonna go on the ropes
that's cheating
god it's cheating huh they built this to
be done this way and by god I'm gonna do
with you son [ __ ] I don't know why whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa ah come on it's
[ __ ] impossible oh wow okay yeah sure
let's do that what else fast okay we got
this it's easy it's easy it's easy it is
easy it's easy oh it's easy I am holding
jump to bounce higher off a flip turtle
I am oh you know that's the thing about
this game like I guess it's different in
a good way like everyone knows what to
do right everyone knows what you need to
do it's just doing it and executing it
that's the only thing so you know
there's no real trick that's like no
jump with the Rope oh we're doing it
like you know it's not really that
because I could but also the grubs
finicky too it's like we all know it
needs to be done here so let's just all
band together whoa we're such a close
call there Bubba
why on the Rope for this only this
segment because otherwise it would be
cheating right I'm just gonna I was
right there there was a checkpoint right
in front of my freaking face no why
would you slide I'm only I'm literally
pressing the directional oh I forgot god
damnit I was just oh I wanted to stop
and talk to you guys but I forgot that
I'm on a red board no oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god yeah Jay Jay
yeah yeah yeah yeah got a lot of [ __ ]
cooking means that was a better bounce I
don't know why suddenly I'm getting a
better bounce out of this but let me
just
Oh Danny Boy the pipes no boys are cool
don't want that I hate this I hate this
why would I want this now oh you messed
me up
you must be up with bad Oh
oh my god I'm losing it I'm losing it
I'm losing all my time
why are apart now nothing I can't do
this is simple this is simple it is so
simple why is this the thing now okay
there I think there we go that is gonna
concentrate okay you wait wait okay you
go all the way to the very edge uh-huh
yes again Jack I get that I did that
okay
huh he ignore you Gogi huh yeah huh that
was the first one oh my god it's nothing
but it's nothing but turtle jumps why
God no that was bad one ah well there
you go then I had a saving grace and
then I lost it
well I bumped that too soon now I'm
boned gonna jump on the rope because I'm
a cheating bastard cheating bastard
bird oh that felt good to do turn now Oh
what what did you even hear I only hit
up it's the only button I press in this
goddamn game
[Music]
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine I'm
fine
we're all fine here every one time that
pigs fine fell off into the abyss got
speared up its own butthole by Spike
that's fine as I said all fine that time
I went intentionally that I got all okay
don't go yet you go all the way to the
edge good
so won't learn anything let me know that
was bad one
okay that was a good bounce house the
less good bounce that was good one okay
getting it oh sweet delicious checkpoint
of the gods for you stay there all right
God I'm not gonna quit oh I'm not
quitting I'm not I'm not I'm smiling I'm
smiling at means I'm happy right if you
smile you're happier right that's what
happens when you smile you did send
happiness blood gene through your blood
and get happy no why no okay oh my god
oh my god are you kidding me God why
can't I do this anymore it's the very
beginning it's the very beginning it's a
sequence it's such a simple sequence for
advance for jump jump forward that's all
it is that's how you do those jumps you
just a either fit forward first or jump
first and you go shorter or farther and
it's super easy why am I not doing it
Oh Rick Oh
oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light I'm gonna nail my balls to the
wall I'm gonna cut off my nipples and
glue them to my toes I'm chopping and
chopping one shot baby one under mine
from whence marker one punch man Teague
I'm gonna punch bandicoot ah no that was
bad I could tell I felt that in my blood
nope nose oh yeah that's good too and
then a little bit but not oh yeah there
we go oh yeah got this on nope now Stu
gonna take the rope gonna take the rope
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah oh these are oh these
are good curses oh these are good
journaled with soft underbellies oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no
can't do this with directional pad why
am i doing it with no how are you there
I don't know I don't care here we go I'm
gonna play with my head because again
I'm gonna broken dude you know what [ __ ]
you I'm going on the road don't do that
you get over there I'm gonna jump on you
now with the goddamn control oh it
physically hurts me in my grundle would
physically hurt me oh I heard me I'm
gonna get cuz I'm a winner baby don't
you believe how much quitter
I'll feel my wedding drama Quinn I'm
going back to that I'm going back to the
other one nope you know what this was a
mistake I can tell it's no dick on his
pals yeah Jana was right and my shadow
wasn't on it and fled off yes I would
like to retry I'd like to go on mr.
bones wild ride one last time nope that
wouldn't have made it
it is gonna make it
what in the world
why does sometimes I'd bounce out of a
turtle and it does a short jump it does
it on purpose
it's like is that Marta bark I'm not a
fan of him no no I'm more of a beautify
kind of guy I'm more of a Logan Paul I'm
a member of the lo gang I wouldn't have
anything to do with this oh this is the
one I just concentrate stop being such a
prick not it's fine that's fine it's
fine everything's fine I'm just gonna go
[Music]
yeah oh my god oh my god what happened
what happened what happened is you
Marga Blair you've changed beam went to
your hand
oh I'm desperate oh [ __ ] it now all
right I don't want to game over again I
don't want to do it I'm not even halfway
through this level which is the worst
part Oh
no god damn it [ __ ] up oh I'm trying to
[ __ ] concert I really am I'm I've
never been so trihard in my life not
even own like twenty twenty modes have I
been this trihard but oh my god you are
[ __ ] kidding me I'm gonna do this I'm
doing it legitimately because one it's a
point of pride at this point why are you
so difficult it scares the piss out of
me every goddamn time Oh No oh my god I
was right there haha hey I just called
mock off oh [ __ ]
nope
yeah okay yeah there we go okay
checkpoint life this girl this thing
that okay got it oh yeah that's a good
stuff oh yeah it's a good stuff
this I can handle pigs I can handle all
day I could take care here's all day
okay to me give it to me like earn this
I don't know I thought I was gonna bread
the needle but did it so I guess that's
good oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
umm I see that up there oh well I was
gonna go get it but I can't now so I
guess I'll just dance with the pants off
got it anyway oh boy is there something
out there oh my god there was but now I
can't get it yes I can Oh ho-ho
[ __ ] off what why did you are dive okay
you wait I'm gonna wait for you and then
you tell me when you're ready
oh no oh no oh no oh no go back go back
oh my god oh my god nope nah I didn't
feel that one over there somebody made
it hate me so much hate it so much it is
it is everything I abhor oh how I guess
I'll come back for those no that's the
opposite of good I'm sorry then you can
afford that because you can do that as
many times as you need but I'm not going
to get away from getting those goddamn
bonuses at least they didn't put this
bonus platform off the ledge because
that would be real shitty of them okay
straight down got it okay come on
someone give me a light one of you
better have a life in you okay well
there's the lives okay got two lives
that's good and I'll probably get
another bonus from the Apple that's good
I'm almost there
I've got to be the last stretch just
these Turtles it's fine I got this
these turtles aren't even that hard oh I
see what you're doing here no oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh don't do sideways
what your shadow was there oh my god one
last piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] before I'm
off there you just had to send me off in
style right you just had to do it or
else you would have been so mad at
yourself because why not oh my god imma
go home
yes yes yes yes I'm shoving my face to
you now yes I did it there we go
I'm happy everyone's happy everyone's
happy I did it
great so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna keep going on this
one
like I said gotta beat the gay behind
one thing maybe not but either way thank
you everybody who believed in me thank
you everybody who didn't believe in me I
heard your cheers all the way from the
future which it was when you saw it but
I think all of you if you remember at
6:14 p.m. July 7th July 7 6:14 p.m. if
you felt a disturbance in the force at
that point on that day oh those me
that's babe oh that was me
okay so anyway thank you everybody again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]